the market for culture art is huge
unfortunately almost all the native art
that you find either online or in stores
features fake Native American art when I
walk into a store and I see cultural art
from my community that's counterfeit it
feels like a family photo on a product
in a store it feels that personal to me
and I wanted to do something about it
[Music]
my name is Louie Gong I'm a nuke sack
tribal member and I'm the founder of
eighth generation which is based at Pike
Place Market in Seattle when I walked
through the mall
almost every store has Native art on
products in it and not one of those
products is connected to a native
artists to me that represents a huge
problem and eighth-generation tries to
address that problem by creating actual
opportunities for cultural artists to
develop products I'm a self-taught
artist and about 10 years ago I started
doing art by customizing a pair of shoes
and I had developed a really strong
organic following from doing that work
we know that people want to buy native
art so that eventually became the
foundation of eighth-generation
[Music]
we have about 15 different business
relationships with makers within two
miles of Pike Place Market when you buy
products featuring
are done by native people and produced
by Native owned companies you're
strengthening the cultural art and the
communities whose artwork you like we're
the first Native owned company to offer
wool blankets this is important because
the aesthetic of wool blankets has
largely been native when people think of
wool blankets they think of Native art I
think people are used to seeing native
people in one of three categories
you know we're typically a charity
project or a symbol of history or a
symbol of the natural environment we're
planting a seed about who native people
really are and so when they walk in the
door the message that gets conveyed is
that we're alive and we're thriving and
that contradicts what people want to
think about native people
[Music]